das ukrainische Volk wurde heute mit dem
Sacharow-Preis des Europaparlaments
geehrt wichtiger als diese Anerkennung
sind für viele Menschen aber die
finanziellen Hilfen eine Milliarde Euro
hat die Geberkonferenz in Paris
beschlossen damit das Land irgendwie
durch die kalten Monate kommt die
Zivilbevölkerung leidet weiter ohne
Strom ohne Wasser Verhandlungen sind
nicht in Sicht und Forderungen nach mehr
Panzern gerade auch aus Deutschland die
werden wieder lauter das war auch Thema
heute im Bundestag der ukrainekrieg im
Winter was kann der Westen noch tun
unser Thema heute in der phönix-runde
Phoenix Runde
aber kein einziger von putinsplänen ist
aufgegangen weil Putin sich getäuscht
hat über den Mut der ukraineren Ukraine
über Europa über uns über den Charakter
unserer Demokratien über unseren Willen
und zu widersetzen gegen Großmacht waren
und Imperialismus der Bundeskanzler
heute morgen in seiner
Regierungserklärung zum EU-Gipfel ich
begrüße Sie ganz herzlich aus Berlin und
darf in meine Gäste vorstellen bei uns
ist Alexander Liebmann er ist Professor
für Politikwissenschaft mit Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Russland hier an der
Freien Universität in Berlin geboren ist
der in Moskau gustav ist bei uns Militär
und Sicherheitsexperte des European
counselations und herzlich willkommen
Ute Fink Krämer Vorstandsmitglied der
Plattform zivile Konfliktbearbeitung das
ist ein Netzwerk von friedenspolitischen
Initiativen und sie war auch einmal
Abgeordnete für die SPD
und herzlich willkommen Daniela proger
sie ist freie Korrespondentin und
berichtet seit 2019 aus der gesamten
Ukraine vor allem für die
österreichische Tageszeitung der
Standard und ist uns heute Abend
zugeschaltet aus Wien herzlich
willkommen
Herr kressel wir haben es eben gehört
der Bundeskanzler hat gesagt Putin habe
sich getäuscht und hat noch mal deutlich
gesagt dass man auch der Ukraine eben
entschlossen geholfen hat stimmen Sie zu
wie entschlossen hat Deutschland die
Ukraine bisher unterstützt also ich
würde dem zustimmen wenn wir am Ende der
Fahnenstange wäre oder Krieg ist ja noch
lange nicht vorbei und Putin hat dazu
gegeben dass der Krieg länger dauert aus
russischer Sicht aber er hat immer noch
den Sieg vor Augen der sieht das Ziel
einen einen Siegfrieden zu erreichen
also die gesamte Ukraine zu unterwerfen
und in das russische Imperium
einzugliedern immer noch immer noch als
das Kriegsziel immer die man also
nacheifer zu lange das leider der Fakt
ist kann man eben noch nicht davon reden
dass wir gewonnen hätten oder dass wir
über den Berg werden oder dass die
Unterstützung reicht weil wir sind immer
noch in dem Prozess und wir sind immer
noch dabei uns dabei zu finden die die
Unterstützung zusammen zu kratzen die
Ukraine braucht um diesen Krieg dann
letztendlich über den Verlauf des
nächsten oder übernächsten Jahr zu
auszugewinnen aber es wurden ja ziemlich
viele Milliarden jetzt bereitgestellt um
der Ukraine weiter zu helfen ist das ein
ja was für ein Zeichen ist das in
Richtung Ukraine also zuerst mal gibt es
den Finanzrahmen der russland zeigt was
auch immer du für ökonomischen Schaden
für sozialen Schaden in der Ukraine
anrichtest wir fangen das auf wir
finanzieren den Funktionalität des
ukrainischen Staates der Krieg kostet ja
40 Millionen pro Tag das fangt bei der
Munition an und hört bei den Gehältern
für das Sanitätspersonal für die für die
Retter für auch für die
Arbeitslosenunterstützung es gibt ja
kaum noch
werkstätige Arbeit jetzt in der Ukraine
zu verrichten auf und diese Kosten
bleiben irgendwo liegen ähm die zweite
Komponente ist aber natürlich die die
Ukraine steht im Krieg und braucht ein
militärischen Nachschub braucht
militärisches Gerät das jetzt auch aus
dem Westen kommt kommen muss aufgrund
der Zerstörung der eigenen
Rüstungsindustrie und da sind die
größten Fragezeichen aus meiner Sicht
gesetzt wir haben die panzerdiskussion
der Ukraine gehen langsam aber doch die
Munition für Kampfbahn zu östlicher
Bauart aus wenn sie genauso wie bei der
Artillerie westliche Kaliber verschießen
will dann braucht sie auch irgendwo
einen Panzer wo durch die Kanone diese
Munition passt und da kommen wir dann
schon in fischigere Gegenden wo sich
gerade Deutschland schwieriger tut als
beim Bereitstellen von Geld genau da
sprechen natürlich gleich noch mal
ausführlicher darüber Frau Brugger heute
morgen gab es ja wieder Angriffe auf
Kiew Drohnenangriffe wenn wir das immer
sehr kressel ja gerade gesagt hat dass
wir ja natürlich über die militärische
Unterstützung dann auch sprechen was
hören Sie sie sind im Moment in Wien
haben aber jetzt ja ganz viel Zeit in
Kiew verbracht waren bis vor kurzem da
und haben natürlich auch Kontakt zu
ihren Freunden dort was hören Sie was
bedeutet das diese Drohnenangriffe der
heute morgen wieder
ja ich habe mich heute Morgen natürlich
sofort erkundigt wie es meinen Freunden
geht in Kiew die meisten sind durch die
Explosionen aufgewacht heute morgen eben
nicht durch den Luftalarm denn das ist
ja ein Geräusch mit dem die Bewohner in
der Ukraine seit Monaten leben und sich
deshalb auch an dieses Geräusch gewöhnt
haben und das muss man auch immer wieder
sagen also dieser Krieg dauert ja schon
Monate lang an in manchen Teilen des
Landes auch schon acht Jahre und ja
diese Angriffe mit Drohnen und Raketen
die hören nicht auf wir leben die in
Kiew seit Anfang Oktober hier hat sich
bis dahin eigentlich relativ weit
entfernt von der frontlinge angefühlt
auch lief im Westen der Ukraine aber
Russland schafft es natürlich mit diesen
konstanten Angriffen auf die ziviler
Infrastruktur aber eben auch auf die
Strom und heizversorgung dafür zu sorgen
dass sich die Bevölkerung in der Ukraine
mittlerweile vor einer
zweiten Front wiederfindet nämlich vor
der energiefront und darauf versucht
sich die Bevölkerung natürlich schon
seit dem Sommer vorzubereiten das war
auch klar dass Russland die
Infrastruktur angreifen wird allerdings
kann man sich nur bis zu einem gewissen
Punkt auf diese Angriffe vorbereitenden
die werden ja nicht aufhören auch in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten und das was
jeder persönlich für sich tun kann ist
natürlich sehr begrenzt und auch das was
die Regierung für die Bevölkerung tun
kann mit diesen
aufwärmenzentren die ja jetzt überall im
Land eröffnet wurden das ist immer ein
Tropfen auf den heißen Stein solange
Russland nicht mit den Angriffen aufhört
schauen wir gleich noch mal später noch
mal etwas genauer auf die auf das was
die Energie
Situationen auf die Energie Situationen
der Ukraine noch eine Frage weil das
jetzt gerade diese Drohnenangriffe gab
wird dann auch eine Forderung laut nach
mehr Abwehrsystem weil die helfen ja
dann letztendlich
die Rolle die diese Abwehrsysteme
spielen die sind sehr große und deswegen
werden die natürlich auch gefordert man
darf auch nicht vergessen dass
mittlerweile ein großer Teil der
Bevölkerung in der Ukraine wirklich
sämtliche Namen und Modelle von Waffen
kennt einfach weil dieser Krieg wirklich
jeden betrifft und sich durch jede
Familie zieht und deswegen fordern
natürlich auch die die Menschen dort
also eben nicht nur die
Regierungsverantwortlichen sondern auch
die Menschen in der Ukraine das mehr
Luftabwehrsysteme geliefert werden denn
wie wir sehen heute morgen sind ja
absolut erforderlich um dafür zu sorgen
dass Russland nicht noch mehr
Infrastruktur zerstört aber eben auch
Menschen tötet dann bei diesen Angriffen
kommen natürlich auch immer wieder
Menschen ums Leben und man darf auch
nicht vergessen dass jedes Mal wenn die
Schäden behoben werden wenn wir über die
Infrastruktur sprechen Menschen ihr
Leben riskieren um eben diese
Reparaturen durchzuführen
bleiben wir mal bei diesen
Abwehrsystemen Frau Krämer sie haben
sich gegen zu viele Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine ausgesprochen wenn Sie das
jetzt für was Frau Brugger schildert die
Menschen gerade auch seit Oktober seit
dieser Angriff noch mal so verschärft
wurde auch Richtung Kiew wenn Sie das
hören warum möchten Sie nicht das
Abwehrsysteme geliefert werden
also ich habe nie gesagt dass ich nicht
will dass Abwehrsysteme geliefert werden
ich habe immer gesagt wir müssen auch
alles andere was getan werden kann um
die Situation für die Menschen zu
erleichtern im Blick bleibt und auch in
den Finanzierungsplänen bleibt noch und
das ist ganz aktuell sowas wie
humanitäre Hilfe aber auch eben die
Lieferung von Systemen mit denen man
zumindest Lokal Strom erzeugen kann von
Wasserversorgung
Wasseraufbereitungssystem
klassische humanitäre Hilfe
Medikamente
medizinisches Material das alles wird ja
auch zerstört und wird dann benötigt und
es reicht eben nicht Abwehrsysteme zu
liefern sondern es wichtig eben das zu
liefern was die Menschen zum Überleben
brauchen aber und würden sie werden sie
auch bereit zu sagen wir müssen doch
mehr schwere Waffen wir müssen Panzer
liefern also mich wundert immer dass die
USA zum Beispiel keine Panzer liefern
denn es ist ja nicht so dass jetzt
Deutschland wahnsinnig viel überzählige
Panzer rumstehen hat noch und da bin ich
Diplomatin eher als als als
militärexpertin noch ich glaube nicht
dass Deutschland ausgerechnet das erste
Land sein sollte was Panzer liefert wo
wir das ja auch teilweise tun erlebt man
was sagen sie hat er heute im Bundestag
in der Debatte hatte
Oppositionsführer März hat noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass eben Kampf und
Schützenpanzer fehlen das ist eben
wichtig ist dass die Ukraine diese
Gerät bekommen was finden sie sollte
Deutschland liefern ich glaube
tatsächlich ist das sagt uns viel mehr
darüber wie die deutsche Debatte abläuft
und viel weniger darüber wie die Lage in
die Ukraine an den ist wir müssen das
einfach ehrlich zugeben deutsch ist es
keine entscheidende Kraft im Sinne von
Lieferung von Waffen und kann auch
angesichts der Lage der Bundesrepublik
angesichts der Lage der Bundeswehr nicht
diese entscheidende Kraft zahlen die
Entscheidung der Rolle werden die
Vereinigten Staaten übernehmen was aber
Deutschland machen sollte und da stimme
ich Ihnen völlig zu ist keine ganz
entscheidende Rolle bei dem Wiederaufbau
der nicht nach dem Krieg anfangen soll
sondern gerade jetzt jetzt braucht die
Ukraine massive Stärkung der Resilienz
der Energieinfrastruktur und das kann
Deutschland leisten das kann die
deutsche industrielleisten und da ist es
absolut sinnvoll auch sehr viel Energie
und sehr viel finanzielle Mittel zu tun
aber es heißt es gibt auch Panzer die
man liefern könnte es ist für mich
einfach nicht die zentrale Frage jetzt
um ganz ehrlich zu sein wenn wir
Deutsche Debatte sprechen
wird also in Europa über die deutschen
Panzer nicht weggehen das Problem dass
Europa hat ist dass es sich ja
in den vergangenen 20 Jahren im Grunde
auf einen Kampfanzug oder
Anführungszeichen geeinigt hat so dass
im Grunde der Leopard 2 der europäische
Kampfpanzer ist das überall vorhanden
und dass man wenn man aus Europa
Kampfpanzer liefert um den nicht umhin
kommt die Frage nach amerikanischen
Kampfpanzern stellt sich auf allerdings
sind die in der Lieferung in der
Logistik etwas schwieriger jetzt
bereitzustellen als der deutsche Leopard
2 bei den Amerikanern was mich eher
verwundert ist dass sie keine
Schützenpanzer liefern weil Bradley
gibt's auch nur für sich in den USA
genug wir sind noch im besseren Zustand
als die als die dortigen Abrams die man
ja am Polen an Australien ausliefert das
Problem ist nur man kann in diesen
Fragen nicht lange Pingpong spielen und
Ausreden erfinden und sich
hintereinander verstecken die die
ukrainische Armee braucht mechanisierte
Reserven ohne die ist dieser Krieg nicht
nur nicht so gewinnen ohne die ist die
Verteidigungsbereitschaft der Ukraine
nicht aufrecht zu halten und da gehen
diese ganzen Ausreden die
eben auch in Deutschland beschworen
werden einfach nicht mehr lange aus
irgendwann muss die Entscheidung jetzt
fallen was die Ukraine was an was man
welchen System wir die Ukraine ausbilden
wollen was wir einführen wollen damit
auch im Frühjahr auch über den nächsten
auch über das nächste Jahr hinweg die
Einsatzfähigkeit der mechanisierten
Reserven erhalten bleibt und wenn wir da
in eine Situation kommen wo wir im
Frühjahr unter dringendster munitionsnot
irgendwas liefern müssen dann bringen
wir die Ukraine da in höchste Gefahr und
das sollte vermieten werden man muss
aber doch jetzt erstmal durch diesen
Winter kommen also vielleicht schauen
wir da noch mal drauf was denn die
Ukraine im Moment jetzt eigentlich am
dringendsten braucht um diesen Winter zu
überleben nur das Problem ist das geht
nicht so ein Waffensystem braucht eine
Zeit der Ausbildung des Soldaten der
logistischen Vorbereitung also Olaf
Scholz hat Ende Mai ihres Tee
angekündigt und das Waffensystem wurde
dann Ende Oktober geliefert das ist auch
bei anderen Waffensystemen so das geht
nicht auf Knopfdruck das heißt man muss
immer vor planen schauen wo gehen der
Ukraine gewisse Ressourcen aus was
brauche ich für Vorlaufzeit um das zu
bedienen und wie wie und wann nach
welchem Takt muss ich das Einfädeln das
bei der zivilen Infrastruktur ja auch so
also Generatoren oder Transformatoren
vor allen Dingen energietransformatoren
stromtransformatoren die haben über ein
Jahr Wartezeit bis ich die bekomme das
würden Sie denn sagen jetzt mit Blick
auf den Winter was brauchen die Menschen
in der Ukraine am meisten sie sind ja
auch gereist die Waren in Don Bass wir
können auch zwischendurch mal auf eine
Karte schauen da sieht man noch mal
genauer
noch mal genauer die Ukraine wie ganz im
Westen und das sind die Türkei türkisen
Gebiete sind die die Ukraine wieder
zurückerobert haben also nach dem was
sie sie haben einen guten Überblick über
die dann über das ganze Land was wird da
im Moment am trinken gebraucht damit man
durch den Winter kommt
ganz ehrlich die Menschen brauchen Strom
und die Menschen brauchen eine Heizung
um durch diesen Winter zu kommen und das
ist natürlich nicht überall im Land
möglich gerade wenn wir über die ehemals
besetzten Gebiete sprechen wo ich auch
vor kurzem war im dornbas zeigt sich ein
Bild der absoluten Zerstörung man kann
es nicht anders beschreiben also ich war
in Städten wie ein easium oder in limane
die einfach großteils zerstört wurden
durch die Kampfhandlungen und auch dort
wohnen immer noch Menschen die seit
Monaten keinen Strom haben und keinen
fließendes Wasser vor allem in Liman ist
die humanitäre Situation sehr sehr
schlimm ich habe da Menschen getroffen
die seit Monaten in ihren Kellern leben
weil ihre Wohnungen und ihre Häuser eben
teilweise oder ganz zerstört wurden und
deshalb auch nicht beheizt werden können
und man sieht da Menschen die vor den
Häusern Holzhacken mit Holz dass sie in
Wäldern gefällt haben in die man
eigentlich gar nicht reingehen soll weil
die noch immer vermiet sind und und man
sieht Familien die in ihnen Höfen und
Hinterhöfen kochen das heißt die
Situation ist hier wirklich ganz
schwierig für die Menschen und die
Regierung versucht auch gerade aus
diesen Gebieten die Bewohner in andere
Landesteile zu evakuieren weil man hier
auch nicht dafür sorgen kann dass es in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten wieder
eine Stromversorgung geben wird oder
fließendes Wasser oder eben eine Heizung
und das ist wirklich ein Bild dass ich
in den unterschiedlichen Regionen auch
zeigt eben vor allem in diesen Gebieten
die befreit wurden vor allem auch in
mich Version und generell im ganzen Land
ist es so dass sich die Bevölkerung
darauf einzustellen versucht dass dieser
Winter einfach unfassbar schwierig wird
dass es Blackouts geben wird dass man
wahrscheinlich auch in einer frierenden
also in frierend in der Wohnung sitzen
wird das heißt hier werden
Stromgeneratoren gekauft aber ich denke
wenn es wirklich minus 10 - 15 Grad
haben sollte und die Menschen
gezwungen sind dann werden er sie auch
aus Städten wie Kiew fliehen müssen
vielleicht in angrenzende Regionen aber
vielleicht auch in EU-Ländern Kiew hat
beinahe drei Millionen Einwohner und ist
eine moderne Stadt die von Strom
abhängig ist und ich denke man darf ja
auch nicht vergessen dass man über die
Würde der Menschen spricht wenn man von
diesen Situationen erzählt wenn man sich
das vorstellt dass man dazu gezwungen
ist Schnee auf dem Balkon einzusammeln
um zu Hause Wasservorräte zu haben oder
sich an den öffentlichen Brunnen
anstellen muss einfach nur damit man
seine Haustiere damit man seinen
Haustieren Wasser geben kann dann ist
das natürlich eine sehr entwürdigende
Situation und deswegen sind die Menschen
natürlich auch wütend dass Russland sie
dazu bringt eben genauso zu Leben
erlebt meine Frau von Krämer wenn Sie
das Hören diese Schilderungen und diese
also müssen wir ja müssen wir noch
stärker oder wie wie können wir denn
jetzt stärker dann doch die Menschen
unterstützen die schauen Sie dann auf
diesen Winter ja ich erwarte in diesem
Winter leider nichts Protest weil die
russischen Angriffe fortgesetzt werden
sie haben auch die grafragen über die
Abwehrsysteme gestellt also Patriot
steht jetzt in der Debatte unabhängig
davon wie die Entscheidung jetzt fällt
von dem was ich gelesen habe spielt und
da braucht man unter normalen
Bedingungen sechs Monate für die
Ausbildung des Personals das petriot
bedient und der Einsatz von
nato-personal in der Ukraine alle einig
ist 100% ausgeschlossen egal was
passieren wird dieses Risiko kann man
nicht annehmen weil es ein katastrophale
Eskalation bedeuten kann das heißt man
muss einfach realistisch sein russland
hat da Eskalation hatte Möglichkeit den
Angriff auch ukrainische kritische
Infrastruktur vorzusetzen aber der
Winter setzt ja auch der russischen
Armee zu also oder ist die viel besser
da auch bestimmt macht das die russische
Armee im Winter auch offensiven
durchführen wird ist ja die eine Frage
die andere Frage ist ob man Luftangriffe
fortsetzen kann mit Drohnen und mit den
an der anderen Ausrüstung der russischen
Armee zur Verfügung steht und
meine Befürchtung ist dass diese Art von
Angriffen grundsätzlich sehr lange und
sogar unter extrem ungünstigen
Bedingungen fortgesetzt werden kann was
für mich auch bedeutet dass man
einfach realistisch sehen muss schauen
muss auf den Ausmaß der Zerstörung der
noch Leiter in diesem Krieg kommen kann
das würden Sie sagen was wäre das
wichtigste jetzt wie man in diesen
Winter geht also ganz sicher zu gucken
was in der Europäischen Union an
Generatoren an
Wasseraufbereitungsanlagen an Know-How
zum Umgang mit Abwasser da ist noch weil
wahrscheinlich auch abweise
Wasserleitungen teilweise zerstört
werden wenn
irgendwelche Raketen einschlagen und
dass man da quasi Geld und Know-how was
ist beides in Deutschland gibt zur
Verfügung steht wir haben das Technische
Hilfswerk was ja ein Stück weit auch
eine Besonderheit ist
und wo eben auch dann wahrscheinlich
Techniker aus der Ukraine ausgebildet
werden können
grenznah und dann mit den Geräten in die
Ukraine zurückfahren und sie da direkt
einsetzen können und da weiß ich da
braucht man keine sechs Monate also zum
Anlernen
schneller ich würde trotzdem immer gerne
mal fragen wie weit wir wie was ich
militärisch ändern kann sie haben dafür
sie haben gesagt sie haben von Zuständen
wie im ersten Weltkrieg gesprochen was
meint sie damit genau sich die Fronten
anschaut schaut das so aus wie ein
Wetter also Russland greift die anderen
indem es stark mit Artillerie den Gegner
zerstört und dann sozusagen eine Welle
Infanterie vorschickt mit Panzern um die
Stellungen einzunehmen die man vorher
zur Chancen hat dann bis jetzt man diese
Stellungen verlegt das Artillerie vorher
in die Tiefe und und schießt sich weiter
vorwärts so
primitiv läuft unter Anführungszeichen
der Krieg ab weil die Russen im
März April die Erfahrung gemacht haben
dass sie mit tieferen op so eine so
schnell tief in ukrainische Tiefe zu
stoßen sich nur Probleme einhalten sie
ihre Funkgeräte nicht gut sind dass ihre
Koordination nicht wirklich klappt und
so braucht man das im Grunde nur mit der
Uhr koordinieren bis X Uhr schießt man
in die erste Linie bis y wenn die zweite
Linie und damit weiß jeder wann er bis
wann vor zurück hat
das heißt dass der die russischen
Angriffe sehr langsam vor sich gehen das
heißt aber nicht dass sie jetzt nicht
unter den Ukrainern auch Verluste
erzeugen gerade dieses dieses heftige
Artillerie Trommel Feuer ist für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte enorm
Korrektiv weil sie eben zu wenig
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge haben um Transporte
in und durch dieses Artillerie Feuer zu
benehmen Schützenpanzer kann ich da
durchfahren aber wenn zu Fuß in
vertreterialverteidigungskräfte zu Fuß
die Arbeiten sich dann wirklich von
Graben zu graben von granatrichter zu
granatrichter vor wie wir das aus Filmen
im Westen nichts Neues kennen und das
ist natürlich eine blutige Angelegenheit
und es bindet dieses verteidigen von
bachmut und Umgebung ja auch erhebliche
ukrainische Kräfte das ist nicht so dass
sozusagen nur weil wir jeden Tag die
Meldungen hören Angriffe wurden
zurückgeschlagen dass das ohne Verluste
abbiegen und das ist ohne gefallene
abging dramatisch kann die Situation
auch für Russland werden also kann es
dadurch dass die Situation vielleicht
dass die Ausstattung da nicht so gut ist
dass es dann auch im schwieriger wird
für Russland in diesem Winter
weiterzukommen für Russland sind die die
Verluste an Menschen ungleich höher als
auf der ukrainischen Seite das erstens
dadurch dass man die Leute wirklich in
den Tod schickt und verheizen solchen
Angriffen das zweite ist dass ihr die
Kommandanten auch gar nicht Fürsorge
tragen für Soldaten das verwundete nicht
geborgen werden dass hier entsetzliche
Zustände herrschen aber das Problem ist
das Regime Putin stützt sich ja auch in
den politisch auf macht Gewalt und Druck
Ausübungen nicht auf auf demokratische
Legitimität und das ist in den den
Machthabern in Moskau zu einem sehr
hohen Grad egal wie viele Leute da
verheizt werden
es gibt eine Analyse auf einer unab
studienzeitung der Moskau times die
sagen das immer weniger Menschen in
Russland glauben dass das eine gute Idee
war die Ukraine anzugreifen das heißt es
ist von Kriegsmüdigkeit die Rede ist das
eine Einschätzung die sie teilen ist das
ja ist das inzwischen spürbar in
Russland wir haben jetzt eigentlich zwei
entgegengesetzte Entwicklung in den
Russland und die eine geht tatsächlich
in die Richtung von der sie sprechen
neulich wurden auch die Daten von einer
geheimen Befragung gelegt die
angeblichen FSO durchgeführt wurde dem
russischen einem der russischen
Sicherheitsdienste nachdem über 50% der
russischen Bevölkerung jetzt
Verhandlungen unterstützen würden und
nur 20 bis 30 Prozent für den weiteren
Krieg stehen das ist der eine Trend
tatsächlich die Kriegsmüdigkeit leider
gibt es auch den anderen Trend und den
muss man offen benennen je mehr
russische Soldaten an der Front fallen
desto mehr russische Familie
mobilisieren sich und radikalisieren
sich natürlich das sind auch gefallene
Freunde sind auch gefallen der Kameraden
und unabhängig von dem Anlass unabhängig
von dem Grund für den Krieg entsteht
auch der Wunsch die zu kämpfen
entsteht auch der Wunsch irgendwelchen
Sinn dem Tod zu vergeben und wenn die
Lage so weitergeht insbesondere mit der
mobilenmachung mit möglichen neuen
Wellen habe ich unglaubliche Furcht dass
irgendwann der Krieg auch nicht nur
Putins Regime mobilisiert wird was jetzt
passiert ist sondern auch zu massiven
Veränderungen der Stimmungen in der
russischen Bevölkerung führt wo auch die
meisten Russen sagen werden der Krieg
muss weitergehen es muss einen Sinn
haben und dann sind wir also es kann
schlimmer gehen okay also sie sehen im
Moment noch keine positive Entwicklung
dass man das dann eine Bewegung ist die
sagt wir müssen damit aufhören das sehe
ich überhaupt nicht das ist auch Sie
haben Recht ein autoritärer Staat so
einfach ist es auch nicht
setzen sie wollen ja gerne das
Verhandlungen irgendwie möglich gemacht
werden das wäre ja sozusagen eine
Voraussetzung dazu noch eine Aspekt denn
es gibt ja für die Familien immer zwei
Möglichkeiten das eine ist die Söhne in
den Krieg ziehen zu lassen und das
andere ist den Söhnen zu helfen ins
reinzukommen und wenn wir nicht nur
diese politische Zusage hätten vom
Bundestag das eben Deserteure und
kriegstes Verweigerer aus Russland
aufgenommen werden in Deutschland
sondern wenn wir tatsächlich so was wie
ein Korridor aus den Ländern wo sie noch
ohne Visum hinkommen also
Istanbul Türkei oder Georgien aufbauen
würden und sagen würden so wenn ihr auch
nur plausibel machen könnt dass euch
eine Einberufung bevorsteht also nicht
erst wenn ihr die einen berufungspapiere
habt und dann ist noch Schaft
rauszukommen sondern wenn ihr plausibel
machen könnt ihr wollt euch diesen Krieg
entziehen und eben nicht in Georgien
bleiben könnt auf Dauer oder in Istanbul
dann kriegt ihr hier Asyl in Deutschland
bis dieser Krieg vorbei ist damit
könnten wir den Familien eine
Alternative dazu bieten dass ihre Söhne
in den Krieg ziehen müssen und ich
glaube das wäre sehr hilfreich ein
anderer Punkt wo man noch indirekt
unterstützen kann auch aus friedenspolit
meiner Sicht ist dass man die Kräfte in
Belarus unterstützt die eben gegen eine
Einbeziehung von Belarus in diesen Krieg
Arbeiten ich habe heute mit einer
menschenrechtspolitikerin aus Belarus
dem Augenblick im Exil lebt dass einer
Bundestagsabgeordneten vorgestellt diese
Arbeit da kann ganz viel passieren denn
das sind vielleicht nur 20 30.000
Soldaten die Lukaschenko beisteuern
könnte aber wenn man das schafft die
rauszuhalten aus diesem Krieg dann ist
das auch für die Ukraine
rauszuhalten und eben auch damit
lukaschenke und nicht auf die Idee kommt
eben auch kriegst es verweigere aus
Belarus aufzunehmen und schließlich muss
man natürlich auch in der Ukraine sagen
das ist ein demokratisches Land die
haben keinen formales Recht auf
kriegsverweigerung aber die die nicht
kämpfen können und wollen auch die
müssen notfalls Asyl kriegen
einsetzen
aber ich glaube es Bruchteil dessen wo
wir unsere Debatte schauen müssen wir
diskutieren sehr viel über
Panzerlieferungen diskutieren aber gar
nicht unbedingt darüber welche Wirkungen
die Maßnahmen die jetzt in der EU
ergriffen werden tatsächlich auf unsere
Fähigkeit haben irgendwas in Russland zu
verändern wir haben jetzt Verbot des
russischen des eines ist wichtigsten
unabhängigen regimekritischen Senders
dosht in Lettland aus ehrlich gesagt ich
sag's ehrlich sinnlosen Gründen die
glaube ich niemand ernst zu nehmen
tragen würde und auf dieser Weise hat
diese Entscheidung den Versuchen in
Russland etwas zu verändern und den
Krieg zum Ende zu führen massiv
geschadet darüber bräuchten wir genauso
viel zu reden ob wir Leoparden liefern
oder nicht okay ich will von Frau Probe
gerne mal einen binden Frau wenn man
jetzt schaut es wird ja viel darüber
gesprochen dass die dass der der Mut der
Kampfes Wille bei den Ukrainer noch so
stark ist und äh das heute gab es den
Sache Aufpreis für das ukrainische Volk
ist das ein Punkt wo sie sagen ja dass
das
jetzt auch weiterhin und es gibt eben
ganz wenige Menschen die sagen wir gehen
nicht in diesen Krieg obwohl die
Verluste so hoch sind
denn Menschen die in der Ukraine leben
die haben ja nicht die Wahl zu sagen sie
wollen mit diesem Krieg nichts zu tun
haben der Krieg zieht sich durch das
gesamte Land und wie ich vorher gesagt
habe durch mittlerweile fast jede
Familie da geht es darum dass Menschen
fliehen mussten gestorben sind gefallen
sind verwundert wurden dass Menschen
ihre Häuser verloren haben ihre ihre
Wohnungen zerstört worden sind ihre
Zukunftspläne genommen wurden dass ihre
Arbeit verloren haben das heißt man
kommt diesen Krieg ja nicht nicht aus
das heißt die Menschen wissen dass sie
hier für ihre Freiheit und für ihr für
ihr Leben eigentlich kämpfen und zwar
nicht nur mit Waffen sondern eben auch
damit dass sie die Soldaten oder eben
die anderen Mitmenschen unterstützen
indem er sie zum einen zum Beispiel
Lebensmittel zur Verfügung stellen aber
auch einfach indem man solidarisch ist
und man weiß natürlich dass das
ukrainische dass dieser ukrainische
Widerstands Willen kommt ja nicht dass
es halt diesem dann gibt es ja nicht
erst seit diesem 24 Februar sondern die
ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung die hat in den letzten
Jahren ja gezeigt dass sie sich nicht
unterkriegen lässt es gab in der Ukraine
mehrere Revolutionen man hat hier dafür
gesorgt dass die Ukraine eben eine eine
aufstrebende aufstrebende Demokratie
wird und genau das hält man in der
Ukraine übrigens auch der russischen
Zivilbevölkerung oder der russischen
Bevölkerung fordern man darf ja nicht
vergessen dass er sehr viele in der
Ukraine Verwandte und Freunde haben in
Russland oder dass sie dort gearbeitet
haben oder ihren Urlaub dort verbracht
haben und da gab es vor allem in diesen
ersten Tagen und Wochen des Krieges sehr
viele Gespräche auch mit eben Verwandten
und Bekannten in Russland die ja sagen
dass sie den Ukrainern und Ukrainerinnen
nicht glauben wenn es zu Angriffen kommt
und das nimmt man der Bevölkerung in
Russland übrigens sehr übel und da sehe
ich auch sehr wenig Spielraum dass man
hier die gelungen zwischen diesen beiden
Bevölkerungsgruppen wieder relativ bald
wieder eben vielleicht ja beleben kann
oder dass es hier noch mal zu einem
Dialog kommt dann in der Ukraine sieht
man dass die dass die russische
Zivilbevölkerung zuschaut dass die
Bevölkerung mitmacht und man sieht hier
eben die Menschen in Russland auch als
eine Art Komplizen verehren wir doch mal
gibt es denn überhaupt irgendwie eine
Chance dass man sagt also der
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat vor dem
Ausschuss der deutschen Wirtschaft
gestern gesagt also es muss auch nach
eine Kooperation mit Russland wieder
möglich sein wenn der Krieg beendet ist
also er hat das ist ja sozusagen so eine
kleine Türöffnung also sehen Sie
irgendeine Möglichkeit man sagt ja in
irgendeine Richtung der
Verhandlungslösung zu kommen
hat er eine gewisse Position zu Ostern
da Kanzler will auch diesen Leuten
gefallen und dann wird halt gesagt das
Problem
ich nehme solche Dinge überhaupt nicht
ernst
die Frage die man sich berechtigt
stellen kann die aber auf dieser Welt
überhaupt keine Antwort gibt dass die
Frage ist erstens wie endet dieser Krieg
und und wie verändert sich Russland
durch diesen Krieg das Problem ist ja es
ist ja nicht nur putinskrieg sondern es
gibt eine eine Elite eine Macht Elite
die da Sowjetunion nachhängt und die
diesen diesen autoritären System dient
und die ihm auch gefügig ist und die in
diesem Krieg ja auch will endlich herbei
geredet und mit unterstützt hat
nach dem Krieg bleibt gut ineinander
macht bleibt die Elite an der Macht oder
oder was passiert in diesem Staat und
davon hängt zu einem sehr großen Teil
lauter und war mit Russland und in
welcher Form man kooperieren kann oder
nicht nur all das ist jetzt
glaskugelschau
auch auch zu
sozusagen im Verhältnis zu uns das große
Feindbild der Westen wenn
tatsächlich in Russland Teile der Eliten
die dem Krieg committed sind aber es
gibt auch große Teile der Eliten die den
Krieg zwar schweigend mittragen aber
offensichtlich den Krieg als Gefahr für
sich sehen als Gefahr für eigene
Interessen als Gefahr für eigene Pläne
und gewinne diesen Menschen eine Tür
öffnen zu halten und sagen wenn sich
etwas ändert man mit den trotzdem in
Dialog kommen könnte erhalte ich für
eine ganz klugen und durchdachten
Schritt weil wenn diese Menschen sagen
werden und das sagt übrigens jetzt das
russische offizielle Fernsehen neulich
gab es in einer der Talkshows die
Aussage wenn Russland den Krieg verliert
damit jeder die einzige Russe und jede
einzige Russin auch wenn Sie im Ausland
sind werden alle ihr ganzes Leben lang
operationszahlung bezahlen da wird jeder
auskremel nach Den Haag gebracht zur
Prozessen dann werden diese Eliten auch
ja dann sehen sie keine Alternative als
den Krieg bis zum Ende zu Unterstützung
das wollen wir nicht deswegen eine Tür
offen zu halten halte ich schon für ganz
ganz wichtig
was erlebt man gesagt hat zu diesem
Sender Deutsch noch also unabhängige
russischsprachige Berichterstattung über
die Deutsche Welle über sowas wie
Deutsch über vielleicht noch andere Exil
sende dass man das unterstützt dass man
auch bei den EU-Nachbarländern dafür
wirkt das zu unterstützen noch ist das
eine das andere ist
Wissenschaftskooperation
Wissenschaft ist ja mit Russland die ist
ja da ist ja alles kaputt also ist ja
alles aber es ist zum Teil auch vom
Westen abgebrochen ja so natürlich ist
das nicht denn warum soll man die
Kooperation in Bezug auf
Sprachwissenschaften
russische Wissenschaft obwohl sie
wussten wir riskant das Essen Aufruf
gegen diesen Krieg unterschrieben in den
ersten Kriegstagen das sind 15000 Leute
wo komplette gucken können mit wem
kooperieren die in welchen Ländern und
hätte diese Kooperationen stärken können
die ganzen in Anführungsstrichen
unpolitischen Wissenschaften
Sprachwissenschaft wo es ja auch darum
geht dann zum Beispiel deutsch russisch
also über klassische Literatur sich zu
verständigen über Linguistik sowas wie
Archäologie sowas wie
Geschichtswissenschaften könnt ihr alles
weiterlaufen und wo es eine
Wissenschaftskooperation gab und gibt
die jetzt praktisch versucht in
Drittländern sich zumindest informell
noch zu treffen ist die ganze Forschung
zu Abrüstung und Rüstungskontrolle da
gibt es eine Trilaterale Kommission
US-amerikanische Wissenschaftler
russische und deutsche die treffen sich
jetzt im Augenblick in Istanbul oder ein
ähnlichen Orten um weiter zu überlegen
wie man diese
rüstungskontrollpolitischen Themen die
ja Themen zwischen Russland und den USA
sind wie man die aufrecht erhält das ist
jetzt genau die Frage kressel ist das
ein Punkt wo man sagt es ist
letztendlich liegt es Patienten der USA
dass irgendwelche das ist irgendwie ein
Anfang von Verhandlungen gibt
nein weil die USA kämpfen nicht aktiv
also
einzuwirken natürlich auf Russland in
irgendeiner Weise das früher Russland
der Part ist der nicht verhandeln will
bisher ist ja klar dass das Problem ist
wir sind in diesem Krieg noch nicht in
einer erwartungssituation wo Putin sich
gewillt sieht ernsthaft zu verhandeln
wenn er sagt es müssen Aktionen
anerkannt werden über Gebiete die
Russland gar nicht kontrolliert dann
zeigt das ungefähr wie ernsthaft er das
meint also wir haben wahrscheinlich noch
ein Jahr wenn ich zwei Jahre Krieg vor
uns bevor Putin so weit militärisch
erwartet ist dass sie sich wirklich zu
Verhandlungen bereits sieht und bis
dahin ist das alles Schall und Rauch und
sind Überlegungen die man anstellen kann
aber es wird bei Überlegungen bleiben
Probleme gibt wo verhandelt wurde und wo
auch weiter verhandelt werden kann das
ist das getreideabkommen nee also
landwirtschaftsgüterabkommen
landwirtschaftsgüter und und Düngemittel
es ist verhandelt worden über
saporisch ja worüber wir noch gar nicht
geredet haben dass da eine ein riesen
Risiko ist von einem schweren Atomunfall
mitten in Europa und je nach
Windrichtung trifft es dann auf jeden
Fall immer die Ukraine aber eben
entweder auch Russland selber also
steigt auf Russland zurück deswegen
gewisses verhandlungsinteresse oder eben
nach Norden nach Westen trifft es
EU-Länder
es ist ein zweites Beispiel und über
Gefangenenaustausch wird regelmäßig
verhandelt und diese diese Ebene der
geostrategischen Rüstungskontrolle und
Abrüstung ist ja auch ein Konfliktpunkt
zwischen Russland und den USA der
praktisch begleitend
vertrauensbildend wirken kann wenn was
auch gemacht wird von den USA aus dort
Vorschläge gemacht werden und
Verhandlungen geleitet werden genauso
ist übrigens auch Diplomatie das was
Olaf Scholz in Peking gemacht hat dass
er nach Peking gereist ist und sich mit
dem Präsidenten
Chinas hingestellt hat und gemeinsam
gesagt hat Atomwaffen dürfen nicht
eingesetzt werden und da keinen
Umständen also auch sowas ist Diplomatie
und
letztlich wird China eine Rolle spielen
positive Beispiele wo es irgendwie
funktioniert eine Rolle spielen und das
das mit zu befördern da kann Deutschland
was tun da können die USA was tun Frau
Prora wie wird das in Kiew gesehen wie
schaut man auf diplomatische Versuche
gibt es da irgendwie glaubt man an so
etwas gibt es auch ja so etwas Hoffnung
dass es doch mal bewirkt etwas bewirken
könnte
Verhandlungen kann es erst dann geben
wenn auch die Ukraine zustimmt dass sie
bereit ist zu verhandeln und so wie wir
das ja auch von der Regierung hören ist
das jetzt auf keinen Fall möglich für
die Ukraine dann der Krieg findet auf
ukrainisch und Territorium statt und die
Schäden und die Auswirkungen wird die
ukrainische Bevölkerung Jahrzehnte mit
sich tragen werden und für die
ukrainische Bevölkerung steht auch klar
dass die Grenzen wiederhergestellt
werden sollen dass es eben auch um eine
rückkehroberung des Territoriums geht
50% der Gebiete die ja von Russland
temporär besetzt wurden wurden ja schon
wieder zurückerober das heißt man sieht
ja auch diese Erfolge die die Ukraine in
den vergangenen Monaten durchaus
erreichen konnte man darf nicht
vergessen dass in den ersten Kriegstagen
und Wochen ja immer davon ausgegangen
wurde dass die Ukraine den Krieg sowieso
verlieren wird und ich glaube hier
geht's einfach auch ganz klar darum dass
man
die Diplomatie gerade einfach dass man
da Diplomatie gerade auch gar nicht
vertrauen kann wenn man über Russland
spricht gerade vorher wurde das
getreideabkommen erwähnt und eben der
Hafen von Odessa wenn wir uns
zurückerinnen einen Tag nachdem dieses
Abkommen beschlossen wurde wurde der
Hafen von Odessa wieder mit Raketen
angegriffen das heißt aus ukrainischer
Perspektive heraus sind haben Abkommen
Verhandlungen und eben verschiedene
diplomatische Lösungen mit Russland
gerade keinen Sinn und auch keine
Wertigkeit und man erhofft sich hier
eben auch vom Besten standhaft zu
bleiben und eben auch nicht bei den
Sanktionen klein beizugeben und man darf
auch nicht vergessen dass hier auch noch
ein anderes Land mittlerweile eine Rolle
spielt nämlich der Iran wenn wir eben
über verschiedene Waffen sprechen und
das heißt hier wartet man sich eben auch
nicht sofort nach Verhandlungen zu rufen
denn das hat gerade auch ukrainischer
Sicht einfach sehr wenig Sinn also wir
müssen uns wenn ich es richtig verstehen
auf dass der Krieg noch länger dauert es
heißt ja dass
also der ukrainische Außenminister
Kollege erwartet eine große Offensive im
Januar und Februar
worauf basiert man das also was denken
Großteil der mobil gemacht und
russischen Soldaten noch nicht in
Ukraine eingetroffen also von diesen
300.000 etwa 300.000 mobil gemacht
hatten Männern sind 70 bis 100.000 in
der Ukraine und der Rest ist noch in
Training im Belarus in Russland und mit
dem Eintreffen dieser Kräfte
wird natürlich das was jetzt im bachmut
geschieht dann wahrscheinlich auch einen
anderen Teilen der Front geschehen und
die Ukraine macht sich da auch große
Sorgen erstens dass es nicht die letzte
Welle der Mobilisierung ist sondern das
ist weitere Wellen nachdem die Leute
jetzt aus den Kasernen draußen ist
weitere Wellen an mobil machen geben
könnte das zweite ist dass Russland
Druck auf Belarus ausübt auch diesen
Krieg beizutreten und dann von Norden
noch mal eine zweite Front eröffnet wird
und ja das sozusagen ist ist die ist der
Gedanke mit dem man in das in das
nächste Jahr geht und die die Ängste die
man hier jenseits der Raketen hat
ein anderer Diskussion die dann ja immer
auch folgt wenn wir über unser
Verhältnis zur Ukraine ist sprechen ist
die Frage der Flüchtlinge auch das ist
ja möglich dass das ansteigt der lebt
man womit rechnen Sie und denken sie
dass die Unterstützung des Westens und
auch Deutschlands anhält wenn noch mehr
Flüchtlinge kommen das wäre sehr
wünschenswert aber da muss ich ehrlich
gestehen habe ich meine Zweifel ich habe
gerade neulich die Nachrichten gelesen
dass sogar in Polen obwohl da die
offiziellen Zahlen der Unterstützung für
die geflüchteten extrem hoch sind also
soziologische Untersuchungen gibt
qualitative die zeigen dass es immer
mehr Zweifel gibt in der Bevölkerung es
ist einfach für alle Gesellschaften eine
ganz große Herausforderung und es wird
eine sehr sehr große Herausforderung
auch für Europa bleiben
und die dass die neuen Wellen kommen ist
sehr wahrscheinlich also weiß ich das
richtig verstehe sagte behauptet die
ukrainische reg sagen dass jetzt in
diesem Winter die Leute eher in die
ländlichen Gebiete fliehen werden wo es
auch gereizt werden kann aber es werden
die Leute auch nach Europa kommen und es
wird nicht einfach Frau Brugger sehen
sie Anzeichen dafür dass mehr Menschen
angesichts der ja der Kälte da doch auch
in die EU kommen sie haben es ja vorhin
vom Don Bass beschrieben dass die Leute
da eigentlich nicht weg wollen obwohl
die Situation ja so schlecht ist
ein großer Teil der Menschen die
geflohen sind sind ja in andere
Landesteile sind in anderen Landesteilen
untergekommen und die Menschen mit denen
ich spreche die in der Ukraine leben die
wollen nicht fliehen die wollen Ihr Land
nicht zurücklassen und die sagen auch
dass sie gar nicht wissen wo sie jetzt
noch vielleicht unterkommen sollen denn
diese ersten großen Fluchtbewegungen die
sie am Anfang des Krieges gegeben hat
die haben ja auch gezeigt dass eben
viele Menschen in EU-Ländern
mittlerweile geblieben sind und hier
fragen sich viele ob es überhaupt noch
Platz für sie gibt ihm im Ausland und
natürlich wird es so sein dass die
Menschen wenn sie wenn sie eben
vielleicht erfrieren könnten ähm fliehen
werden das ist klar also ich glaube hier
ist es auch einfach menschlich
nachvollziehbar dass man versucht zu
überleben viele erkunden sich eben ab
befreundet ob Freunde eine Dacia haben
also ein eine kleineres Haus außerhalb
der Stadt oder in den Dörfern wo man
unterkommen kann weil man dort eben auch
mit Holz heizen kann aber das ist auch
alles keine langfristige Lösung und das
heißt hier wird sich in den nächsten
Wochen zeigen ob sich wieder mehr
Menschen aufmachen werden um eben das
Land zu verlassen denken sie dass die
Diskussion um Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine noch mal die Diskussion über
Unterstützung grundsätzlich noch mal
beeinflussen wird
ja ich glaube es eigentlich ein weniger
es gibt eine sehr hohe Solidarität ich
glaube hier ist auch die die Bevölkerung
gerade in Deutschland auf progressiver
als die Regierung was die Unterstützung
der Ukraine angeht geht auch viel
Unterstützung aus der Gesellschaft
heraus
es wird natürlich eine Frage der
Quantität sein das ist es immer so man
muss jetzt auch sehen durch diese
Stromausfälle die Ausfälle an den fernen
Heizanlagen an in den Städten die haben
ja wenn Sie zu einem kälteren Zeitpunkt
passiert etwas im Oktober wo in Kiel für
30 Stunden die Heizung Weg war
ganz andere Auswirkungen weil wenn die
Wasserleitungen in diesem vor allen
Dingen in diesem Wohnblocks einmal
Durchfrieren und wir großflächig
Wasserschäden dann im Frühjahr haben an
diesen Häusern da wird natürlich ein
Großteil der Bausubstanz in denen sehr
viele Leute leben einfach schlicht
unbewohnbar und dann dann stehen wir vor
einem ganz anderen kein Problem vor dem
wir jetzt stehen dann müssen wir mit
diesem Problem aber dann auch irgendwie
umgehen also man kann die Leute nicht
zwingen in in
einsturzgefährdeten Wasser aufgeweichten
Häusern zu leben das geht weder in der
Ukraine noch irgendwo anders vielleicht
ganz ganz kurz noch zum Schluss Frau
Brugger wir haben ja auch viel geredet
über das Geld was die EU was der
Bundestag was Deutschland zur Verfügung
stellt gibt es eigentlich irgendwas was
man als Privatperson tun kann von
Deutschland aus
also es gibt ja verschiedene
Organisationen die in der Ukraine tätig
sind vor allem auch viele ukrainische
Initiativen also kleinere Organisationen
die vor Ort sind und vor Ort helfen bei
größeren Organisationen ist die
Bürokratie manchmal etwas hinderlich
dann verzögert sich meistens ganz kurz
noch was braucht man was wird am meisten
gebraucht
ich glaube am meisten kann man da
derzeit wahrscheinlich wirklich mit Geld
spenden auch die Initiativen vor Ort
unterstützen die es ja schon gibt okay
vielen Dank Frau Prober Stromgeneratoren
ist glaube ich etwas was wichtig ist
vielen Dank Herr gräßel Frau Finn Kremer
und Herr Lippmann für diese Diskussion
wir sind morgen wieder für Sie da dann
schauen wir auf den EU-Gipfel im
Schatten der Korruption der u-gipfel in
Brüssel und jetzt geht's hier weiter mit
Phoenix der Tag bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]